bonjour je m'appelle reine elle vit je
suis étudiant en troisième année de
droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines par rapport aux
qu'ovide scocco vite c'était quand même
assez compliqué on a dû changer quand
même beaucoup d'habitudes par exemple
moi j'avais pas du tout l'habitude de
travailler chez moi je travaille jamais
chez moi j'étais je passais toutes mes
journées à la biotech en général et mes
week-ends aussi donc enfin vraiment tout
le temps et d'un coût de 2 voire
complètement changé de cadre c'est assez
compliqué sur la biotech ça vous fera
enquête est quand même assez agréable
sans ça c'était
c'était pas facile surtout quand on a
été pas mal livrés à nous-mêmes mon
colis des trous donc c'est très très peu
encadré en plus on me disait que ça
allait être le diplôme à l'est rien
valoir que ça qu'est ce qui vous fait si
leur style cool car
là on est un peu en paix dans l'afrique
au vide et il ya un peu un truc de année
vous vous à la génération collier donc
vous êtes vous êtes nulle par rapport
aux autres vous avez pu même niveau les
fautes 3 mains de rattraper ce niveau à
ce niveau là par exemple la plateforme
qu'on doit avoir taillé une plateforme
pour les admissions aux masters je suis
amusé en master c'est très compliqué
c'est chaque fois qui fait qui fait ce
qu'elle veut c'est chaque émission est
géré comme la fac elle en a envie
typiquement son postulat à 20 fac pour
créer un compte quand on crée nos
comptes c'est en même temps de faire nos
devoirs on est en plein examen côté et
on a en plus des contacts et on a deux
mille trucs à faire donc déjà cette
plate forme ça serait quand même ultra
ultra avec important l'impression que ne
pas exister les étudiants tasse on l'a
toujours dit depuis surtout depuis qu
vite des étudiants sont pas existé ce
qui est normal quand on essaye de
préserver l'économie à cause du peu vide
bah évidemment les étudiants
s'inscrivent à l'économie donc très
rapidement ses 500 des deux côtés
[Musique]